[Applause]
[Music]
oh
well i feel rather frightened i'm
so afraid he will look just like
everyone else
he does you are my little cousin
cecily i'm sure you are under some grave
mistake
i'm not little in fact i do believe i'm
actually more than usually tall for my
age
but i am your cousin cecily and you i
see are also here helping joe michael
resides with their tedx talk
and you are my cousin ernest
my wicked cousin ernest oh well i'm
not really wicked at all cousin cecily
you mustn't think that i'm wicked well
i hope you haven't been leading a double
life pretending to be good
and being really wicked all the time
that would be hypocrisy
well of course i have been rather
reckless
i am glad to hear it but the world is
good enough for me
cousin cecily yes but are you good
enough for
it i'm afraid i'm not that that's why i
want you to reform me
well i'm afraid i have no time this
afternoon the ted talk and
all well would you mind my reforming
myself this afternoon
oh it's rather quixotic of you but i
think you should try
good i feel better already you're
looking a little worse
well might might i have that pink rose
why because you are like a pink rose
cousin cecily well i don't think it
could be right for you to talk to me
like that
you are the prettiest girl i ever saw
well
well well i i you know i and and
um and all good looks are a snare and
and and well they just know that every
sensible man would like to be caught in
and
i'm so sorry i am
i i didn't finish rehearsing
um well it's not because i can't walk in
heels i i'm actually really good at that
and i can prove it to you too but i
really am sorry
uh um
no matter no matter
right right introductions it's a tedx
talk
right hi there
my name is joe michael rezas and i'm a
phd student here
in theater and performance studies and i
specialize in the study of queer
identities as they maneuver
and affect the perceptions of time in
the performance of camp
you know camp um
sincerity in irony's clothing
making the kitsch feel like home no the
met gala theme from 2019 that was
thoroughly misunderstood by over 95 of
its attendees
no okay anyway i'm also an actor
director and theater educator at large
in the greater boston area oh
oh and where are my manners the friends
i brought with me today are algernon
and cecily from oscar wilde's famously
well-known play the importance of being
earnest
and they'll be back don't worry i've
only scared them off a bit
and let's be honest i want to be a tedx
talk without things wrapping up nicely
at the end would it
you know i hope that wasn't too awful
though
it was awkward i know to watch me fail
to feel it
what exactly though to play a man and a
woman
at the same time i mean to play a man
and a woman when i'm actually
neither why does it feel so awkward when
we see someone
fail at gender and why do we care i mean
obviously me screwing this up was done
on purpose obviously i had this all
perfectly memorized and rehearsed for
today right
right well i'm i'm here today to talk
about gender performativity
and the ways in which i've used my
acting classroom as a space to
disrupt the finality of gender
performance to open up
a looser space for thinking about gender
identity through
supportive failure generous mistakes and
honest communication
we all actors or otherwise can play with
gender in our everyday lives
and i call this gender rehearsativity
now
before all of the queer theorists and
women studies degree holders and judith
butler fanatics in the audience start to
tear the half and half hyper binary
costume off of my body
let me first explain where popular
culture has already begun to
misunderstand gender performativity
before i move into the rehearsality i
hold so dear
now as an educator and as a youngish
20-something-year-old trans person i'm
constantly hearing from my
20-something-year-old
students friends and colleagues that
gender is
over that gender is so fluid and
carefree and that society film and
television are so inclusive of
transgender people that it's basically
over now i don't ascribe to the binary
as a non-binary person myself
but gender definitely isn't over or
at least i don't think it is and maybe
just maybe
gender is always beginning
this last semester at roughly
10 23 a.m two of my acting students
while embodying delicious caricatures of
fraternity brothers forgive me i don't
remember his or his name
well they rounded up the class and these
two women in
snapbacks and baggy clothing slacked
their mouths to reveal lax jaws and
lacks bro mentalities
and astounding as it was to watch
these women fluctuated between
irony and satire the uncanny and
the ruthlessly so pain and joy until
ultimately
they failed to be the men they were
choosing to embody
they simply stopped talking silence
a lull hit the class and time seemed to
be sucked clean
out of the room and in this moment of
loud stillness
one of the women still using her frat
bro voice
though fully out of character said
nearly in a whisper
gender is a social construct
i'll admit i laughed along with my
students that morning
partially at the comedic timing that my
student had in her delivery
but also at the fact that society has
turned gender performativity into gender
as
social construct now listen to this
i think that this idea has come from
renowned queer studies scholar
judith butler whose seminal work in the
performativity of gender has gone on to
be a staple
in undergraduate classrooms at liberal
arts institutions
now this spark notes version of butler's
work is found in the idea that
gender exists in repeated words and
actions
and these performatives create and are
created by the bodies of real human
beings
now listen to this moreover in a 1988
essay
butler claims that gender is an act
which has been rehearsed
in this way gender through repetition
becomes a recognizable
script which requires actors to
reproduce it
much like much like my attempt at the
importance of being earnest
oh i mean look at my costume why does
this path make me feel
manly masculine suave and this half
makes me feel girly
fabulous and feminine i mean some of us
even forget that gender is there because
it is so well rehearsed into our bodies
but there's always an ideal of gender
that we can never quite achieve
but it's up to us to play with it now
i've played with gender throughout my
own career as an actor
and in one semester as an undergraduate
student i was cast in two roles
simultaneously brad majors
in the rocky horror show and shalata
ivanovna in the cherry orchard
one man one woman and one
me i would go from one rehearsal playing
the
manly aggressive brad only to be pulled
moments later into
a wig and delicately blended eyeliner as
charlotta
a german governess the constant
push and pull of these identities was
not only invaluable to my work as an
actor attempting to span the spectrum of
gender in my work
but it also revealed to me that my own
queer
identities are deeply indebted to
embodying the extremes of gender
these characters held important facets
of my identities
of my body my daily pain of
my social interactions of my memories
and rehearsing these characters
allowed me to explore those identities
which has opened up my need as an
acting teacher to show the importance of
playing with gender
in rehearsal so
when i present to you all cecily and
algernon
there is this there are these parts of
these two characters that i respect
understand implicitly oppressions i can
relate to fears i can embody
aggressive tendencies that i try to
forget
but there are also of plenty of
characteristics with which i have
no personal experience nothing i can
draw from
and sometimes in a flurry of rehearsal
of reading a script of creating a
character
well we we make a mistake
algernon's aggressive flirtation towards
cecily doesn't sit well in my body or
cecily's calm demeanor as written by
oscar wilde just
doesn't sit right and i literally trip
up
now this tedx talk is a performance in
front of
so many people and it differs quite
drastically from my classrooms in that
regard but
there is such a recognizable pressure in
our daily lives to perform
our gender ourselves on a stage like
this
quite frankly failure to pass as a man
or a woman
effectively is still dangerous for
transgender and gender non-conforming
people
and listen to this according to the 2015
u.s transgender survey
nearly half of respondents voiced that
they had been verbally harassed in the
past year because of their gender
identity or expression
and that number is shown only to
increase in communities of color
many of us now claim to view gender on a
spectrum
and that's great and including 60
percent of generation z individuals who
reported to the pew research center in
2019 that they
believe forms with boxes for male or
female should include more gender
options
but in spite of this there is still
latent fear of making
gender mistakes in offices
in classrooms in the eyes of the
government in romantic situations and
for some of us
even in the mirror when we wake up in
the morning
but our gender mistakes have the
potential for something good
even in the binary approaching life on
the stage as a man or a woman we can
support each other in experimentation
trips in stumbles two hour long
meditations on or
five second costume changes with gender
and failure is a key part of
judith butler's theory of performativity
but i do believe that for most people
like you all out there you might hear
performativity and hear
perform that's to say performance ready
or if not performance ready perhaps
performance
in general gives you anxiety or
the stage fright that i have to this
very day
what we need to understand is that
failing at gender
can and should be a positive generative
process
the mistakes we make with gender can
only help us grow and
better understand the multitudes of
gender around us
but we need to make space for these
mistakes
we need to hold space for failure
and that's where rehearsativity comes
into play
now one of the main points i like to
make with my acting students
when they're last minute panicking about
a monologue or a scene
is that no one is ever actually ready
i mean we're never actually done
rehearsing we're just
put in front of an audience when i
taught a workshop on gender bending this
last
summer at somerville arts for youth i
made it quite clear
to a group of middle school age students
that you cannot be a bully
and a good actor at the same time it's
impossible
there's something about the act of
embodiment that requires
empathy to survive
bullying prohibits the creative process
as these middle schoolers moved about
the room trying on the extremes of
binary gender presentation
this dissolved into glumping
laughter parodying of stereotypes they
see
in movies and on television joy
in the failure to understand gender
even in my college students an
introduction to acting
jumped on the opportunity to play with
gender when i restricted their time to
think
on halloween last year i asked my
students to come to class in
costume and to well to throw their hats
into
the middle of a circle metaphorically
and literally and
the only rule of the game was that they
had to go into the center of the circle
take on a hat pick a character and then
switch
no time to think and it wasn't until
two men in the class noticed no one
running to the center of the circle
that they jumped into the center and one
became
a british chauvinist and the other a
high pr high-pitched decoy british lady
time stood still
laughter mimicry joy
again in the failure to understand
gender that's the potential of gender
rehearsivity
and i challenge you all to think of your
days as mini rehearsals
cultivate spaces in your life to
explore gender and allow
other people to explore their gender
fail
at gender i wish i could give you more
tangible ways to go
out and do this but gender is funny like
that
gender is an act which has been
rehearsed
some acts more rehearsed than others
but gender is far from being perfect
and sometimes just like in rehearsal
when we support each other in times of
play
in times of joy in times of pain
we wind up succeeding more than if we
hadn't hadn't tried or failed
at all well i think that has been a
great success
i'm in love with cecily and that is
everything but i must see her before i
go
oh there she is
i merely came back to water the roses i
thought we were at a tedx talk with the
joe
oh well they've gone to order the dog
card for me
oh are they going to take you for a nice
drive
they're going to send me away oh
so we have to part i'm afraid so
it's a very painful party
well the absence of old friends one can
endure with equanimity
but even a momentary separation from
anyone whom
they've just met is almost
unbearable
thank you
[Applause]